hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about the seven best habits that
you can have in life so one of the more
common questions that I get asked is
Evan you do all this work researching
famous entrepreneurs I want to know what
are the consistent habits that you find
from all these people that we pull
together content from our research what
are the habits that you find equal
success that if I do these things I will
be more successful in anything that I'm
working on and so I've compiled the best
of the best together to find the seven
best habits that you want to do to
succeed in your life habit number one is
ignore the little man so many people I
talked to at that time Felipe they say
this is the stupidest idea you have ever
got my father he said this is an
embarrassment to me and was dumping all
over me I think every time I say I'm
about to do something people are waiting
for me to fumble I just can't live my
life based upon what other people think
about everybody told me you don't need
to do that man some people would rather
kill your dream than see you succeed oh
you don't understand how hard it is to
make it Brendan it's so hard these days
everybody told me you're nuts you can't
do that you can't do that and the people
who are like offended by it doesn't
matter don't ever let somebody tell you
you can't do something along your path
to success you're going to have a lot of
people who tell you that what you want
to do is not possible that it's just
never going to happen for you that you
don't have the skills the talent the
abilities the drive the money the
resources the connections whatever it is
and some of those people will just be
jealous straight up
they'll be jealous maybe they had a
dream that they wanted to chase and they
weren't able to do it and so now nobody
around them is allowed to be successful
they're gonna try to always pull you
down to their level
that's definitely gonna be a chunk some
of the people who hate on your ideas and
there's a little man they love you
they're your parents that your friends
they just see success through their eyes
so success for that person maybe having
a safe steady corporate job for your
entire life that's success and doing
anything else
that's risky that's dangerous you
shouldn't go and do that and so they
want you to live their life and that's
their way of showing you love and so at
some point in your life you need to
figure out if you're going to live your
version of your life or somebody else's
version whether you're going to live up
to your own expectations or you're
living for somebody else's expectations
and when you have that self-confidence
to say I'm living my version of my life
then anybody else who's just trying to
knock your idea down not the ones who
give you feedback not the ones that say
hey here's how you can make it better
it's not just you have all the answers
but the people we're just hating on your
idea and telling you you can't do it
successful people ignore the Motoman
[Music]
habit number two is think big think big
think big big thinking really big big
big ergo big think big dream big one of
the things that I've seen consistently
in the habits of successful people
successful entrepreneurs is that they
don't limit their thinking this ties to
the last point about the little man we
have this vision for what we want to
accomplish a vision what we think is
possible the more that you can expand
that vision the more that you can think
about having a bigger impact to take
that little idea that you have that may
be a huge idea for your community right
like it may be the biggest thing ever
done in your family or in your city and
you want to take it even bigger the
people who have the most success that
people have the biggest impact they're
thinking on a different scale they're
thinking on a bigger scale that's part
of why I made this series I made the top
10 series I made the mentor me series
all of these videos is because I want to
be surrounded by people who are thinking
bigger to help push me to think beyond
my comfort zone because I think for a
lot of entrepreneurs you're surrounded
by people who are small thinking and
they may even say hey you're doing such
a great job you know look at all that
great work than you and look at that big
vision you have and nobody's saying
listen you're doing an okay job like
this is really good but you could be
playing out here you're still playing
small you got to expand your vision you
got expand your horizon and successful
people think bigger and so it encouraged
you to look at is your vision big enough
and when you have those moments of
boldness where you want to be out here
do you then have the environment around
you to support that big thinking on a
consistent basis
be single day not just one day all
excited and then fall back down and the
next month one day all excited and fall
back down consistently think big habit
number three is no excuses you just
makin excuses don't begun excuses you
can find opportunities don't accept
excuses but we've got no time for
excuses and I'll have an excuse no
excuses no cheese's my friends no longer
wallow in my self pity successful people
don't make excuses
it's so easy to make excuses most people
blame somebody else for why they're not
successful right it's the president's
fault it's my country's fault it's the
education systems fault it's my parents
fault it's my friend's fault it's it's
my bank's fault it's always somebody
else's fault right it's easy and it's so
II it's always easy to put the blame on
somebody else because it makes you feel
good because accepting responsibility
sucks saying that your business is not
more successful because of the customers
or the economy or whatever it is it's so
much easier because it makes you feel
good but it keeps you where you are and
successful people the consistent habit
that they have is they accept
responsibility and don't make excuses
your business is where you are because
of you your life is where it's at
because of you your bank account is the
size of your bank account because of you
and when you accept that at the start it
sucks right to say like this really
sucks if this really because of me man I
suck but it's also empowering because
you have the ability to change it you
don't need to wait another X number of
years for a new president to come in you
don't need to wait an X number of years
for the economy to get better you need
to wait for anything just gotta get on
yourself and go make a change successful
people don't make excuses
[Music]
habit number four is work hard work work
work work work work work work work work
work hard work working hard my hard work
work harder and work hard hard work hard
work for all the people out there who
are trying to build a passive income and
are trying to work smart what you need
to do is both you need to work smart and
work hard if you look at the people who
had the most success in whatever field
whether it's in an entrepreneurship or
whether it's at a relationship or it's
whether it's being a parent you want to
be a good parent you have to work hard
at it
you can't put being a parent on
autopilot and make it a passive thing
that just happens and expect to be a
good parent
right you can't put your business on
autopilot and expect to be a great
entrepreneur whatever your goal is
whether it's financial whether it's
spiritual whether it's in the family
whether it's with your business whether
this impact you want to have whatever
your big goal is you need to work at it
you to work smart and you need to work
hard you got to wake up every day and
and go after the torture that you enjoy
the thing that when people look at your
schedule they say that's crazy how can
you work so hard but for you you do it
because you want to because you have an
end goal and so you have to be willing
and able to put in the hours
required to become really great at
something in whatever field again that
you have your goal set up you need to
work hard have it number five is follow
your passion passion passion - passion
passion passion passion action passion
person passion passion passion passion
passion passion passion passion this
ties in with working hard
you only will really work hard and put
in the hours at something that you love
doing you look at the top people any
field they love the work that they're
doing they love it they do the torture
because it's not torture for them they
love the work so many people are
attached just to a goal I need to make
this much money right I want to go buy
that car whatever is I'll do whatever it
takes to get there you won't do whatever
it takes because that goal itself is not
important enough because the work itself
if you hate doing the work
you're never going to become a success
you're gonna quit you're gonna go hard
if it's anything worth doing it's going
to be hard it's going to be a lot of
work and the people who love it who
don't see the work as work will keep
going how many videos do I make a week
how many I make so many videos a week I
do it because I like making videos you
will not be able to keep up with my
schedule of making videos because you
don't love it as much
most people don't love it as much maybe
you're the rare person loves video even
more than me and that's amazing I'd love
to meet you but whatever your goal is
it's great having that angle you need to
enjoy the process successful people
enjoy the day-to-day grind of what they
do because they don't see it as a grind
that doesn't mean that every day is
amazing and happy and all you're doing
is work that you enjoy there's a lot of
crap that comes with it mm-hmm being a
parent there's a lot of crap that comes
with being a parent but you got to do
the work you got to put in the time
you've got to love your kids if you want
to be a great parent and is the reward
is definitely worth it over the pain
that comes with it and some of the down
days that you'll have but successful
people follow their passion habit number
six is gratitude
I always feel grateful for even the
small things grateful be grateful
grateful be grateful be grateful be
grateful I think it's important that you
are grateful for the things in your life
I think entrepreneurs need to be equally
grateful for what they have and wanting
to do more you know I look at if my
channel ends today I'd be really proud
of everything I have I love the life
that I have the friends that I have the
family I have the business that I have I
love it all and at the same time I want
to go and do more because I know I have
the ability to do more I want to reach
more people want to touch more lives I
think too many entrepreneurs are just so
focused on more and more more more more
mobile more more because this in endless
chase because you never get there
whatever you wherever you get is going
to always be more and always going be
more and that Drive is amazing and
entrepreneurs have that in spades just
spending some time being grateful for
what you do actually have can help
balance you out and make you much
happier entrepreneur and I think
it's needed if you want to have success
that gratitude part I think is important
I've had a success practice in my life
for a number of years it used to be I
had a pad of paper by my bed and I woke
up every morning broke down through
things in paper core evolved that into
something I do with my team where every
day they shared something we all share
something in a private Facebook group
that we're grateful for for the day it
also helps you get to know your team
members a little bit more and makes you
realize things that maybe you should be
grateful for too if someone on my team
says they're people for the Sun today
you know like I look at the Sun today
I'm thinking with a side too and add
some extra awareness for you and now we
do it you know on the channel we've had
live gratitude sessions as well whatever
your practice is making it a daily thing
where you're grateful for what you have
as well as being driven to want to do
more is an important habit for a lot of
successful entrepreneurs number seven is
believe believe believe believe believe
believe believe believe believe we
believe we believe we believe believe
believe believe believe believe it
believe believe believe believe believe
believe believe believe
[Music]
so you guys know if you've got made it
to the end of this video if you watch
any of the videos on my channel you know
I'm all about believe I think it's the
core of success in a lot of
entrepreneurs you have to believe in the
work that you're doing you have to
believe in yourself that you can go and
do it and you have to believe that it's
going to work out and successful people
have that belief in themselves that they
can do it and not all the time because
everybody thinks about quitting at some
point and that may mean you need to
watch a video or read a book or be
around friends that can help you build
you back up to get to the point where
you have the confidence to go out and
continue to do it but you need to
believe in what you're doing believe in
yourself and believe that it's going to
work out and I would challenge you that
if you are that person to then not just
settle for that but also be the spark
for other people if you see somebody
else who needs a little bit of belief in
themselves and belief in their work just
saying I believe in you without be able
to give them advice somebody wants to
you know start a makeup line and you
know nothing about makeup just giving
them a little bit of a boost to say you
know what I believe that you can do that
you're really talented I think you'll
make it just a little bit can be the
difference I remember when I first got
comments on my youtube channel just a
few comments coming in made me happy
made me feel like yeah I'm doing
something important and so if you have
that then give it to others if you go on
somebody's YouTube channel leave them a
comment if you see somebody around you
could use a little bit of a boost don't
be afraid of how they're gonna judge you
don't be afraid give them that little
bit of encouragement because it can make
a huge difference in their life so
that's my take on the seven best habits
that you can have in life I'm curious to
know which one did you like the best
which one resonates most with you please
leave it in the comments below also did
I miss an 8 9 10 is something you want
to add to the list to make it an even 10
let me know leave in the comments
finally want to give a quick shredder to
Farooq Syed thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon